a neutron star is the densest body we
know of in astrophysics besides a black
hole if you somehow had a little stone
sized piece of neutron star matter it
would weigh 100 million metric tons and
it would immediately fall right through
your hand because the neutron star is so
dense it generates an intense
gravitational field it is really hard to
exaggerate how dramatic and dangerous a
neutron star is the gravity is so
intense it would actually bend light
around it you would see all these kind
of weird shimmering effects
dazzling but deadly no astronaut will
ever be able to approach a neutron star
but if you're an armchair traveler and
want to find out what would happen let's
send a galactic crash test dummy
we'll call him Chuck as Chuck nears the
neutron star its gravitational grip is
doing very bad things the gravity is
pulling on him so hard that he is
accelerating all the way down to the
surface he'll be moving at very roughly
one-half to two-thirds of the speed of
light the neutron star's gravity is 200
billion times stronger than on earth
around 150 miles above the surface it
starts to pull on Chuck's limbs in a
distinctly unpleasant way as you get
closer and closer to a neutron star we
were told to think that it would be this
elegant spaghettification where you
would get longer like a piece of
spaghetti but in reality you're gonna
get ripped shreds
think about what you're really going to
experience think about first all your
joints dislocated in your body
your skin getting ripped off your body
your bones being pulled apart your
organs being poor to park within a blink
of an eye
our dummy is just a thin stream of atoms
hurtling towards the star those atoms
will eventually fall down on to the
neutron star and unfortunately the
violence doesn't stop there what's left
of Chuck it's the surface triggering a
huge burst of energy so we're talking
about a hundred thousand miles per
second that's an impact he's gonna hit
so hard that the amount of energy
released is just huge it would
completely dwarf the entire arsenal of
nuclear weapons on our planet anything
and anyone that ventures too close to a
neutron star is destined for this
catastrophic end
you